the internet has found one of the most
ridiculous new york city studio
apartments there's a video that got
posted over the weekend and it is going
viral here it is this is what people are
worried about in new york city right now
here's a 235 square foot studio in
harlem that's actually really really
nice and maybe worth the money
first off it's located in a brownstone
on a really nice block with a nice
entryway you have this gorgeous exposed
brick wall a really nice modern kitchen
you even have a dishwasher and a
microwave in there with a decent amount
of cabinet space
then you have those windows in front
which are really really nice and a split
unit heat and a seat with really nice
hardwood floors
you have a closet right here another
half a closet in the bathroom which is
also pretty nice and modern the boiler
takes up half that closet but it's still
good for like suitcases
but it's a really usable space and it's
really nice
this one's 1900 a month
all right a couple of things first of
all we've all lived in new york city so
we know the highs the lows we've been to
friends who have nice apartments and we
don't go to our friend's apartments that
aren't very nice that was actually a
very very nice studio apartment in new
york about 300 square feet give or take
uh and
it had really nice floors had a nice
exposed brick had all the cabinets had a
microwave had a uh actual bathroom the
whole like everything he said in that
video is true which sounds ridiculous to
people outside of new york but inside of
new york that's actually a very very
nice studio you're not buying a two
bedroom you're not getting renting out a
three bedroom you're not renting out a
one bedroom you're getting a studio what
do you expect it's gonna be small it's a
studio apartment the other thing that i
think is really interesting is 1900
is a steal in new york city it's in
harlem so it's not actually in manhattan
but still 1900 bucks for that type of
place i actually think that that's a
pretty nice place that is going to get
snapped up really really quick what do
you guys think yeah i i don't think it's
that bad at all i mean it's relative
right if you've lived in new york city
and you've been to some of these places
and you've experienced all this you get
it a lot more than someone who has never
been to new york city or doesn't live in
new york city 1900 in the midwest for an
apartment like that people would would
literally have a heart attack so i think
it depends on kind of where you're from
and where your experience is but the
thing to remember about new york is it's
all supply and demand right there's
eight million people that live inside of
a very small square mileage city and
they're some of the best restaurants in
the world they're some of the best bars
in the world some different museums and
all these things central park all these
things you can go and do so from simply
a supply and demand perspective like
this is what happens this is why the
rents are so high this is why the places
look like this and this is why some
people are able to get away with this
but i don't think this is one to make a
video about like anyone who's been in
new york is like hey actually that's not
really probably that bad it's like the
yogi berra quote you know uh nobody ever
goes there anymore because it's too busy
yeah that's basically new york normally
right it is like yeah the reason why
there's such high prices is because
demands through the roof john what do
you think i mean it's in a brownstone
it's in harlem it is what 250 300 square
feet it's really not that bad 1900 is
expensive but it's all relative right
when you do look at new york city the
rent is some of the highest in the world
for price per square foot and living in
the city is very expensive so what you
get out of that i think is the
experience of living in new york city
and you get all the things that come
along with that but the actual apartment
itself is pretty nice it's updated it
has nice floors it has just probably
enough closet space for you as a one
individual but you have to understand
it's a studio apartment it's not a
two-bedroom it's not going to be 1500
square feet because if that was 1500
square feet you'd be paying a lot more
than 1900. buyer or seller in terms of
renting that apartment i bet that's
already rented yeah it's it'll go yeah
i have no doubt
what apartments in new york city it's
like you sign on on-site
they go very very quickly the only place
better than new york city is miami but
hey that apartment is pretty nice for
new york city and i don't think that
people should be freaking out if you
want really viral stuff i'm sure we can
find some videos of some apartments
little rats running across no windows no
exposed brick no hardwood floors they
basically just give you a little bit of
a roof maybe half a kitchen half a bath
and they say good luck